i've got good news and bad news the good
news is the coronavirus vaccine is being
shipped
people are taking it it would seem as
though our long national
international nightmare is over the bad
news is
according to the experts even after we
get the vaccine even if
after we get the last dose of the
vaccine
nothing can change you have to keep
wearing the mask
you're not allowed to travel you can't
celebrate christmas
you have to remain locked down i guess
forever this according to the experts on
msnbc
are you getting your uh vaccination this
week uh tomorrow morning and i'm
grateful for it um
chuck i just wanted to say uh just a
follow-up on what yes mean mentioned
just for your viewers out there um i
know one of uh the
individuals who we just saw getting
vaccinated is planning on traveling
after the second dose
i i this is a source of confusion but no
this is one of the misperceptions here
just because you get vaccinated with
that second dose
does not mean you should be
participating in things like
traveling in the middle of an out of
control pandemic or that you're
liberated from masks
everything still applies until all of us
get the two dose regimen we don't think
that's going to happen until june july
but and
again this goes back to what we just
talked about chuck we don't know if
just getting the vaccination prevents
serious illness or does it also prevent
you from getting infection
um entirely meaning you can still get
infected with the virus potentially and
pass it on to others
so really really critical don't let your
guard down just because you got
vaccinated
oh i guess that is confusing because you
see i mistakenly
me i'm inexpert i'm i'm not scientific i
thought that when you got the
inoculation against the virus
you were inoculated against the virus
but you're not
every single person on earth has to get
the vaccine
and also once you get the vaccine you
have to stay locked down forever makes
sense right i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from
john shine who said i hope president
trump's last
three words as president are i'll be
back i think they are actually we played
a clip from the white house christmas
party
a week or two ago where president trump
said look i hope we get another four
years but if we don't i'll see you in
four years
love that kind of attitude i'm still
holding out this kind of sliver of hope
for the compromise of 1877.
unfortunately not looking uh terribly
uh good uh right now and and we just
feel like there's
not much that we can do you know we're
not feeling very well right now
if you're interested however in men's
wellness go to for hims.com
if you need help with erectile
dysfunction hair loss or
if you have a cold if you're interested
in mental health or covid19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get
the prescription medication that treats
ed
real science real solutions to ed you
get the same active ingredient
as that expensive little pill but
without the expensive price tag
no embarrassing conversations this is a
thing that guys don't usually want to
talk about very much
no expensive appointments just answer a
few questions online about your medical
history and a provider
will confidentially review if approved
your medication is shipped directly to
your door
in discrete packaging also shipping
is free if you have this problem and
there are a lot of men who have this
problem
there's a simple solution for it don't
let
the awkwardness of some of these
conversations prevent you
from having a very simple solution try
hymns today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to for hims.com
michael mich ael for your free visit
that is for hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash
michael mich ael prescription products
are subject to medical provider approval
and require an online consultation with
a medical provider who will determine if
a prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that it's
for hims.com michael mich ael
speaking so that kind of medication
that's straightforward enough some of
this other stuff however i'm listening
to the medical geniuses on msnbc and i'm
told that if you get the vaccine you're
not vaccinated
if you get the inoculation you're not
inoculated that you're not
you it's not going to change anything
we've been
talk about moving the goal posts we were
told on march 16th
15 days to slow the spread because we
had to flatten the curve
then flatten the curve became fine to
cure so we got to extend 15 days to 15
months
then we did find the cure we got the
vaccine it's something like 95
effective and we're told well just
because you get the vaccine
doesn't mean you're allowed to live your
life again oh no
you need to lock yourself up in your
apartment forever
and you can't see your loved ones and
you can't live your life you know if
that's what the vaccine does
i don't think i'm going to get the
vaccine if
if getting the vaccine in no way changes
my life
if i'm a young guy statistically i'm at
very very very
very very very low risk of serious
complications from this virus
and the vaccine isn't going to permit me
to do anything new
any any have any of my life or freedom
back
then why would i get it it doesn't make
a lot of sense and there's some people
who did get it who seem to be regretting
that they got it
there i bet there are a lot of people
who aren't going to get it because
they're reading stories about for
instance
a health care worker in alaska who
experienced a quote
serious reaction and was subsequently
hospitalized
after receiving a dose of pfizer's
coronavirus vaccine
which was just approved by the fda last
week this is by the way not according to
some
fringe right-wing conservative website
that this person had a serious reaction
this is according to the new york times
even the left-wing media are admitting
this
uh this person remained in the hospital
as of wednesday
uh the worker had no serious history of
of drug allergies or anything like that
uh though it remains unclear whether
this person suffered from other types of
allergies
but no no a history of drug allergies
and so i think people are going to look
at it and
say wait a second you've got this
vaccine that you've rushed through
very very quickly you know it got the
approval so that's good but you're
seeing
at least now early on this person has a
serious complication from it
and also the vaccine's not going to let
me go back to living my life in any sort
of normal way why would i get it
why would i get it if you look into the
uk the national health service is
confirmed that it's providing quote
resuscitation facilities
in vaccination centers after reports of
two individuals having
uh very serious reactions after
receiving the vaccine now it is worth
pointing out in britain
those two healthcare workers apparently
had histories of allergic reactions so
that could be maybe a little bit more
expected
but still one has to weigh the risks and
this has always been my thought on
not just vaccines but all sort of
medical interventions
there's always risk i know on the left
or maybe the extreme fringes of the
ideological right
people want there to be this perfect
abstract ideological
100 percent you have to do this all the
time there's no argument against it
or vice versa but for conservatives we
realize all of life entails risk
if i were much older if i were in very
poor health
i'd probably say the risk of getting the
vaccine
is is worth it right because it
outweighs
the risk of of just getting the virus
and possibly having a serious reaction
to that
but there is always risk and we're
making these kind of prudential
decisions and this is true when we're
talking about getting on an airplane
this is true when we're talking about
celebrating christmas
this is true when we're talking about
major social issues actually completely
unrelated
to the coronavirus you got to look at
the risk
now whether you get the vaccine or not
it would appear
that the way our statistics are being
counted just about everything is a covid
death anyway
so you could walk out into the middle of
the street and have a heart attack
and if they test you for coronavirus
they'll say yeah this was a coronavirus
death
you could even walk out into a bad
neighborhood get
shot with a pistol
and be counted as a coronavirus death
we've heard anecdotal reports of this
over the past year now uh there is a
state health department
official uh the grand county coroner in
colorado
who is uh standing the whistle on this
saying that the coronavirus deaths in
her county are not coronavirus debts
these people are actually victims of
gunshot wounds
it's absurd that they would even put
that on there
would you want to go to a county that
has really high depth numbers
would you want to go visit that county
because they're contagious
you know i might get it and and i could
die if all of a sudden one county has a
a high death count we don't have it and
we don't need those numbers inflated
so you've got the county coroner who
knows this this kind of information
probably better than anybody says
they're counting these people as
coronavirus debts
they did not die from coronavirus they
may have had coronavirus or they had the
sniffles while they got shot in the head
but the death was caused by the bullet
now they have to count it as a
coronavirus death because the state
health department is making them and
it's not even just the state health
department's fault
it's the cdc is telling the state health
departments to do this
so the cdc has these guidelines if you
die with coronavirus you are said to die
from coronavirus
which means at this point
if you if you believe that the
coronavirus numbers
are not inflated you are peddling a
conspiracy theory
because we now have firm evidence for
months and months and months around the
country
we can say for sure that a significant
number of
deaths that were not caused by
coronavirus are being counted as deaths
from coronavirus so what's the real
number
obviously this is a pretty virulent flu
i'm using flu colloquially it's a
virulent sort of virus but
it is not accounting for all of the
numbers that we're seeing
we know that you can talk to the county
coroners you can talk to health
officials all around the country
and that's to say nothing of financial
incentives for people to
classify these i'm just talking about
the government mandates saying this
must be a coronavirus debt so we've got
some pretty weak information here
you you heard that that medical expert
on msnbc at the top say
look we don't know if you take the
vaccine does that mean that you
can no longer be infected or you just
won't show symptoms or it won't be that
serious or you what
we just don't know well yeah it sounds
like you don't know a lot of things
it sounds like you don't know what what
the vaccine does sounds like you don't
know what the side effects are going to
be
sounds like you don't know what the
primary effect is going to be sounds
like you don't
really know how many people have died
from the virus as separate from dying
with the virus
sounds like you don't know anything at
all experts
actually it sounds like the people who
are in expert and just have a modicum of
common sense
know much more about this than anybody
else the people who say we're going to
live our lives
well for some reason we're still
deferring to these geniuses and lab
coats
and those geniuses and lab coats are
canceling christmas
dr fauci who remains in that job now for
almost a half century
seriously this guy's worked in public
health at a serious
senior level for almost 50 years
dr fauci is saying no christmas the
guy's gotten basically everything wrong
during this coronavirus epidemic
but he's saying you have it's just
science you have to cancel christmas
quote from dr fauci he said this to the
washington post
i'm going to be with my wife period
the christmas holiday is a special
holiday for us because christmas eve is
my birthday
all done hold on
not christmas is a special holiday for
us because it's the birth of our savior
not uh christmas is important for us
because
uh it's the incarnation of the second
person of the blessed trinity
who redeems mankind no which is usually
why people say no it's because it's my
birthday because everything's
about dr fauci it's a special holiday
because it's my birthday oh okay and
then he goes and christmas day is
christmas day
and my daughters are not going to come
home that's painful we don't like that
that's just one of the things you're
going to have to accept as we get
through this unprecedented
challenging time nothing about this
virus is unprecedented it's a new strain
of some kind of virus but new strains of
viruses pop up with some frequency
what makes this unprecedented is the
stupid
incoherent inhuman unconstitute
anti-constitutional
political response to the virus that's
what makes it unprecedented and you know
what
we can fix that in two seconds you know
how you fix that ignore dr fauci
moreover defy dr fauci which i'm
certainly going to do
i'm going to gather with friends and
family and loved ones on christmas
i encourage you to do that as well be
prudent if you have some particular
reason why you're not going to do that
might not even involve health it might
just be that you don't like your
mother-in-law
okay i understand that but as a general
rule
celebrate christmas people don't listen
to this
ridiculous person in a lab coat this
technocrat
who thinks that he can run your life now
he should not be able to run your life
and he by the way he's not the only one
i beat up on dr fauci because he
absolutely deserves it
and because he's the most prominent
public health technocratic tyrant in
this country
but there are people doing this all over
the world they're doing this
in britain too there are calls all over
the place not just don't celebrate
christmas
actually maybe you just postpone
christmas to another time which means
that you are going to have to be waiting
for that knock on your door not just
from santa claus but from your in-laws
all year long and i don't know look if
you are gonna have to do that you have
to make sure that you get a ring
doorbell
it is right now it is doorbell season
right this is the busiest time of the
year you've got packages coming at you
you've got all sorts of people coming
and you want to make sure you know who
is there
definitely true at my house with ring
you can keep an eye on all of this
hustle and bustle no matter where you
are
right from your phone if someone stops
by or something's going on ring lets you
know
and you can see and speak to whoever is
there from anywhere ring makes the
perfect
christmas gift so this christmas season
give someone the gift of peace of mind
this is actually what i
i love most about ring is sweet little
lisa
she can fend for herself okay she's a
scrappy gal she's a good shot
but i like that she can know who is
outside before she has to open
that door it's very very important
i think about this all the time just a
little peace of mind goes a long way and
it's technologically very very
impressive
for a limited time go to ring.com
knowles
k-n-w-l-e-s you'll get special christmas
offers
obviously still time before gift giving
season go to
ring.com knowles my favorite
i've given ring out as a gift to some of
my friends
my favorite aspect of it not just how
impressive it is also how inexpensive it
is so you get
a lot of credit for an amazing
futuristic gift and you don't have to
shell out a ton of cash
ring.com slash knowles canada w l
e s so
not just dr fauci trying to cancel
christmas you have
these sort of more amiable public health
tyrants in the uk saying
well maybe we don't need to cancel it
just uh postpone christmas
the advisors the officials the
scientists in britain
say just have a summer party seriously
celebrate christmas in the summer
i i have friends who have done christmas
in july as a sort of silly
party that's not a substitute for
christmas christmas happens at a real
time and
i think this is one of the sort of
temptations
of liberal modernity is we think that
time doesn't matter
oh you lose a year because fouchy told
you to stay indoors okay that's fine
we're going to live forever it doesn't
matter you don't need to do things in
real time you don't need to do things in
real flesh and blood
you can do it on zoom do it on skype
facetime do it in july who cares it's
all the same it's this
this rationalizing abstracting idea
that is completely antithetical to the
christmas season right the whole the
whole point of christmas
is that this metaphysical being the
source of all creation
the second person of the trinity becomes
incarnate in a particular body in a
particular cave
in a particular place bethlehem at a
particular time
coincidentally zero a.d
what what were the odds of that all
right probably pretty good
in a particular moment in time
that particularity is key i have to
dispel this i haven't done too much on
the war on christmas or the war on
advent which is even subtler
but i have to dispel this myth that
crops up
all the time that christmas the date for
christmas was just chosen arbitrarily
it could it could be july 5th i know we
we picked uh december 25th here in the
west in january 6th in the east
but you know it could be whenever no it
can't
now one explanation for why they picked
december 25th
is uh that early christians decided
that they were going to win over pagans
by
making the incarnation celebration uh to
be
right around you know right on these
pagan feast days and you'll hear that
the pagan feasts will be either the
feast of saturn
or the saturnalia or the feast of the
unconquered sun
soul invictus or the feast of mithras
okay and you
you've by the way these claims have only
been made really in the past
500 years or so is when they've become
really popular and it's just not true
so the uh there's no evidence of any
pagan holiday
on december 25th
before christmas was celebrated on
december 25th the earliest source we
have on this is the
chornography of 354 which does list a
pagan holiday on december 25th
but it also lists christmas on december
25th so there's no evidence that that
that celebration on the 25th predated
christmas saturnalia the feast of saturn
was
established centuries before christmas
but it doesn't quite coincide
saturnalia was originally on december
17th eventually it was extended to be a
long celebration
up to the 23rd so it was a week-long
thing but it still didn't even go all
the way to when we celebrate christmas
no early christian source if there were
really
some uh strategy here to make christmas
sometime around the pagan feasts you
know
on the pagan feasts even the early
christians wrote a lot we have a lot of
their writings
someone probably would have mentioned
this there is no mention of that
at all in any early christian feast the
earliest mention
of even this coincidence doesn't appear
until the 12th century
more than a thousand years after christ
the real reason why it's on
on december 25th is uh because
of the way that they dated the way that
that early christians and
the ancients generally understood a
divine life which was that it had to be
uh perfect perfect in length so
an exact number of years uh you have at
the turn of the third century tertullian
uh dates the crucifixion to uh
march 25th and so if the crucifixion so
good friday is march 25th
then that would mean that the conception
would have to be march 25th and if the
conception is march 25th
then exactly nine months later what do
you have
christmas uh early other christian
writers saying hippolytus of rome said
this that the world itself was actually
created on march 25th so you have the
perfect symmetry of the
conception of christ and the conception
the creation of the world
then nine months later you get christmas
uh saint augustine agrees with this
the uh anonymous christian work on
solstices and equinoxes
agrees with this but but augustine
writes about it specifically and on the
trinity
uh this idea of the conception uh this
would explain the discrepancy by the way
as to why in the east they celebrate
christmas on january 6th
is uh because they also celebrate uh the
the crucifixion on or recognized
crucifixion on april 6th
uh pope benedict made this point just a
few years ago he said there were these
theories that it coincides with pagan
holidays
uh those theories can no longer be
supported the history just doesn't
support it
that is the end of my rant on on moving
christmas and saying that christmas
is you know really just some pagan
holiday it's just not true
is this kind of like when when modern
liberal scientific people
make fun of the old idiot people from
the back old and past days
for thinking that the earth was flat
really nobody thought the earth was flat
no educated person thought that the
earth was flat going back to the ancient
greeks
the idea that people thought the earth
was flat is itself a modern creation
uh it just is absolutely infuriating but
the people who push this stuff or
they're
they give you a fake history they give
you a fake scientific
argument and the people who fancy
themselves to be the most
educated the most serious the most wise
are are often the most ridiculous and a
clear example of this
george clooney george clooney who plays
himself
in every coen brothers movie right he
plays some absolutely
sort of empty-headed actor he has an
argument for you
about how to react to this epidemic
and it's very very scientific he says
put on
an effing mask we're losing 3000 people
a day right now so
that's right you know it's this is gonna
you know we're
it's like you just want to yell at
everybody say just put a [ __ ] mask on
you know
you know this this crazy
where everybody's going well it's my
freedom it's like that's not how this
[ __ ] works
dumbass it's how you know here's your
freedom your freedom is this
you're free to smoke until your lungs
turn black
but you can't do it on the bus right now
and you're free
to drink until your liver pops and comes
out your ass
but you can't drink and then get behind
the wheel of a car there have to be
certain rules this is one that says
put on a [ __ ] mask and we'll get
through this we got vaccines coming
let's save another 60 000 lives before
the vaccines
wow brilliant political philosophy from
george clooney
uh it's like i'm reading lord acton or
something or john locke isn't it uh no
not quite george clooney though if you
take the the sort of profanity
and the arrogance aside which is very
difficult if you took that aside from
george clooney you'd be left with like
three percent of george clooney but if
you
you try to get to the argument he's
making the argument itself is also
extremely stupid
he's making this argument we talked
about it a little bit yesterday this
kind of liberal argument
that look you you can do whatever you
want personally you're completely
entitled to do whatever you want to your
own body
as long as it doesn't affect anybody
else and the reason this argument is
stupid and has never worked anywhere in
the world
is because the things we do in private
have effects in public they do
they have some some more so than others
but if you have a whole society
doing you know lots and lots of vicious
things in private
that is going to have an effect on the
public because the public is just all
the private people
and a clear example of this would be
gender theory right which is you're
allowed to
be a man who identifies as a woman but
don't expect me to call you a woman oh
wait a second that's what the liberal
left is making all of us do right now
how come how come this idea that you can
do anything in private but it can't
doesn't
it can't have any public effects how
come that works when you're talking
about wearing a mask but it doesn't work
on your gender identity
well because it's obviously an
incoherent argument and i'm by the way
i'm not taking
the right-wing libertarian version of
this either i don't
i don't adhere to the argument of
freedom
that george clooney is straw manning and
saying the right wing believes
i don't think that there is no argument
ever
to take certain health precautions that
the government has no right
to institute certain health measures i
think the government does have a right
to do that
i think that the government has during
emergencies has police powers
i just think that the current use of
those powers
is imprudent incoherent and deeply
unjust
and extremely stupid the the freedom
we're talking about here is not the
george clooney
sort of mockery of freedom this idea
that i can pursue my
appetites however i want or i can pursue
my will however i want
i have an idea to use edmund burke the
great conservative philosopher's phrase
of an exalted freedom what i want is a
political freedom
which is i'm not saying that i get to do
whatever i want individually all the
time
but i'm also not saying that i have to
acquiesce to every whim of dr fauci
i have the political freedom in this
country to persuade my fellow citizens
to overthrow the illegitimate regime of
these technocratic public health
expert idiots who don't know anything
who don't know anything about anything
i don't think they know very much about
science capital s with a trademark over
the e and they certainly don't know
anything about political philosophy and
the way this country ought to be run
and i think that we should use our
political power to kick dr fauci out of
his job i think he's been there about 50
years too long
and to to give ourselves our
culture back to allow ourselves to
celebrate christmas
to allow ourselves to see one another
smile and breathe in fresh air and not
wear these ridiculous masks
i think that's very important i do take
safety pretty seriously
and i take freedom seriously but not in
this shallow degraded way
that you hear about mostly from the left
and a little bit from the right
i want an exalted sort of safety that
takes into account all
of uh the many goods in society and i
want an exalted freedom
that allows me to exercise my political
rights in this country
as our founding fathers intended it's
very important to be safe and to be
prudent
and with more online shopping during the
christmas season this year
some experts are saying real experts are
saying that consumers may be
at higher risk of identity theft now
that i know that's
that's for real i've seen that happen in
real time i know that's some serious
expertise
right uh people are falling victim to
deals
that are too good to be true and
sophisticated phishing attacks
experts recommend checking your credit
score not overspending limiting new
retail credit cards
and freezing your credit if needed even
after the holidays it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives get
lifelock
the leader in identity theft protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats
for instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web
it's ver i know you think no one's after
my information ah they'll go for someone
else first they'll attack somebody else
they'll do
you need to protect your information
they are after your information okay
and it's uh an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure now no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
lifelock
can help you feel warm and protected
this holiday season save up to 25
percent off your first year
go to lifelock.com knowles can o w
l e s that is lifelock dot com slash
knowles canada w l
e s for 25 off
i want an exalted political freedom this
is the sort of thing
that rand paul was just talking about
yesterday we haven't even talked about
the election today
i wanted to save that for i wanted to
open up in a way that
that didn't just fill me with complete
fury
and right now somehow the coronavirus is
is the easier pill to swallow the
lockdowns are the easier pill to swallow
to compared to what is going on with our
elections
because we know that irregularities
occurred we know that fraud
occurred we know that illegal acts
occurred
crimes by by election officials
who would pretend that they were going
to stop counting boats for the night and
send all the poll watchers home
the le the poll watchers that the
candidates are legally
entitled to have there and then they
would secretly count the ballots
throughout the night
or they would send the poll watchers
home or you would have these machines
that
that turned up errors that then the
errors would go to a hand count
no no oversight to that sort of thing
what are we allowed to call this out are
we allowed to say this was
this was fraud well at least one senator
is saying we
we can and that would be rand paul i
think we should have hearings going into
the next year
hearing from state legislatures and what
they're going to do
to make sure election law is upheld not
changed by people who are not
legislators and we do have an interest
in that
i don't want it to be federalized many
on the other side of the aisle we'll
just soon federalize it and mail
everybody a ballot and we'll have this
universal corruption throughout the land
but what i think we need to do is keep
it at the state level
but we can't just say it didn't happen
we can't just say oh 4 000 people voted
in nevada that were non-citizens
and we're just going to ignore it we're
going to sweep it under the rug so the
courts have decided the facts the courts
have not decided the facts
the courts never looked at the facts the
courts don't like elections and so they
stayed out of it by
finding an excuse standing or otherwise
to stay out of it
but the fraud happened the election in
many ways was stolen
and the only way it'll be fixed is by in
the future
reinforcing the laws absolutely right
absolutely right now we don't know
i mean this gets to rand's point we
don't know
the full extent of these kind of
illegitimate vote counts
or ineligible ballots we don't know and
i think that's why he said
the election in many ways was stolen
he's not he's not actually claiming
that i know for a fact 100 that trump
got more of these legitimate votes
well you can't know that because the
courts won't take up the case and you
can't know that
because you've got problems that are so
pervasive that you can't possibly go in
and check in every single place but one
thing we can know for sure
is that the way voting was conducted in
pennsylvania was illegal
that was it was unconstitutional the way
that vote was conducted in pennsylvania
the most important swing state
so when rand paul says the election in
many ways was stolen yeah i think that's
a fair thing to say
by the way even if the votes after this
unconstitutional action
even if biden got more of the votes
if the way that the vote was conducted
is illegitimate then
the whole election in pennsylvania is
illegitimate
and yet then the courts come in and they
refuse to hear the case
so what where does this leave us this
leaves us in this morass there's nothing
particularly clear about it i know
ideologues on the left and on the right
really want it to be perfectly crystal
clear and you can have a do-over
you don't get do-overs in politics you
don't you don't get do-overs even in the
courts really
so what rand paul is saying here is look
let's fight this thing to the very end
let's go down to the very last wire
find by me but let's also if
if we lose this battle and it looks like
we will
and i'm just being prudent here or just
being practical i don't i don't see the
route out other than the compromise of
1877 and mitch mcconnell shot that one
down yesterday
but at the very least then you can't
give up the fight generally if you give
up the fight republicans aren't going to
win elections like
ever again okay at least at the national
level at least important elections
decisive elections they won't
if the if the left is permitted to get
away with these kind of shenanigans
how are republicans supposed to win
again so you got to keep up that fight
there are some ways to do it
i think president trump's looking into
it now various
investigators you could appoint senate
could do this as well
but there is a lot at stake here we have
more elections coming up
in january we have other fun stuff
coming up on monday december 21st
the historical docu-series apollo 11
what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com the docu-series takes a
detailed look
at the apollo 11 mission to land a man
on the moon
apollo 11 what we saw is a fantastic
series to watch with your loved ones
over the holiday break
and right now get it for 20 off with
code watch w-a-t-c-h
when you become an insider or above
member over at dailywire.com
subscribe that's dailywire.com subscribe
to get 20
off your membership with code watch and
access to all of our new and exciting
content go to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
i want to get back to this idea of
freedom because i think i i
may disagree with some of my colleagues
here a little bit
and i may sort of a little bit like five
percent defend aoc
but only to make a point about why aoc
is wrong about everything
aoc tweets out yesterday quote
sex work is work the federal government
has done almost
nothing to help people in months we must
pass stimulus checks
unemployment insurance small business
relief hospital funding etc
keep the focus of shame there not on
marginalizing people surviving a
pandemic without help
this is in response to political
controversy
that's been stirring up in recent days
over pornhub pornhub's getting knocked
pretty hard right now which is
great uh over only fans which is this
democratized pornography where basically
this website
lures in any kind of young girl to
[Music]
become a pornographer herself and then
make you know the promises you're gonna
make a lot of money and
the 97 of these people are even
higher don't really make much money at
all but they end up degrading themselves
and have these photos on the internet
forever and it's really not good for
their lives
now i'm skeptical of aoc's premise here
that you know the only way to survive
the pandemic
is to get involved in prostitution and
pornography i don't think that's true
i think there are other ways to make
money maybe maybe you can make
more money per hour or something doing
that but you know the the
costs of that to your reputation to your
personal life to your psychology
you know it's not not great uh i'm
also sort of skeptical that we shouldn't
have shame feel
shame for these kind of lord sexual
behaviors but instead we should feel
shame because
politicians you know haven't done their
job
i think that all people involved in sex
work
and uh politics should probably feel
some shame
you know those are the two oldest
professions right prostitution is the
oldest one and then politics is
just right after that and as as reagan
pointed out
they bear a lot of similarities to one
another
uh however the place i will agree with
aoc and disagree with some of my
conservative colleagues
is when she says sex work is work
obviously that's true
of course it's work it takes time
you get paid for it uh it does require
skill
i won't think too much about the skills
you know because that's not
as a family program but it does it does
require i suppose some kind of
skill even even a little business savvy
to attract a customer or you know it's
so it is work it's just bad work
it's not good work it's not good for
anybody
it's bad for the guys buying the
services it's bad for the women
providing the services it's bad for
society it's bad you know
there was there was a while ago who was
it obama said
i think it was obama some democratic
politicians said you know if you don't
work and study hard you're going to end
up being a barista
being a barista is honest work that's an
honest
you're you know you're going out you're
providing a service i love my barista
you know
sex work and a certain type of politics
is not honest work
but it is work it's just you you don't
you don't want that for you know there
was a troll
who tweeted out obviously this was just
to to troll conservatives into a frenzy
he said i'm my daughter is thriving on
pornhub
and only fans i'm the proud father of a
sex worker
and you know obviously that isn't true
nobody
nobody feels that way because there is
something intrinsically shameful
about looking at porn and about
performing in porn
and people at both sides have
psychological effects from that
you know there's one of the reasons that
pornhub has become such a big issue
is because you've got generations of
young boys who are getting hooked on
this
on this thing which is categorically
different and more categorically more
dangerous than a playboy under your
uncle's bed in the 70s you know or
something like that
this is very different it has very
damaging effects to people
this has been studied scientifically and
obviously that's true ethically as well
and it would seem to me that the way to
attack this problem is not to
stigmatize or marginalize people
who are in it and it's it's not to uh
permit it entirely and just say well
you've got to raise your kids better but
the government has no role politics is
no role
no it's obviously bad it's really bad i
mean it's really shameful of aoc
to encourage young girls to get involved
in prostitution which is what she's
doing
that's that's a shameful thing and that
that could ruin lives
we should not do that we should
discourage girls from getting involved
in pornography and prostitution
we should discourage men from looking at
and engaging in those sorts of things we
can have prudence and recognize
there's always going to be some kind of
shady pictures on the internet
there's always going to be you know a
strip club or a brothel in the red light
district
and there's always going to be the
temptation of women to
get involved in that there's always
going to be the temptation of men to get
involved in that too
but we should try to minimize it you
know even
getting back to saint augustine who i
mentioned earlier with regard to
christmas
saint augustine defended
legal prostitution in the sense that
it's
it's prudent you know it's it's
impossible to eradicate entirely there
can be some externalities
if you do eradicate it entirely but you
don't want to encourage it you want you
know i understand that that's not
satisfying to either the liberal left
who says oh yeah everybody should be a
porn star and to the
extremely ideological rigid right that
says we've got to eradicate lust from
the heart of man
i don't think either of those are
particularly practical i think what we
should just do
is through prudence discourage all of
this activity and that involves some
shame
for everybody involved that can be a
good thing shame is good that's your
that's your conscience having a red
blaring light saying
danger danger don't don't do this and we
should encourage
that faculty that is a faculty of our
reason
that is that is a sense that we should
cultivate so right now
pornhub is getting hit with this 40
million lawsuit
victims of a sex trafficking operation
are
are suing mind geek which is the parent
company
of pornhub because there was a sex
trafficking operation called girls do
porn very creatively titled and uh
basically this was a fraudulent porn
company and they lured the girls in
uh and said that actually these videos
are only going to be released
on dvd in foreign countries don't worry
none of your friends none of your
family's gonna find it what do they do
they immediately upload it
to the internet and apparently to
pornhub in particular because i guess
the biggest biggest website right
so they upload all of that these girls
have their lives ruined
they some of them threaten suicide some
of them attempt suicides
you know their their lives are
completely shattered which should be a
warning sign to anybody
who wants to get on onlyfans.com because
they think they can make a quick buck
obviously effects that you're not taking
into account here and these websites are
preying on girls who are not
taking these things into account so each
victim here
is asking for at least a million bucks
plus they're asking for the profits of
their videos and legal fees as well
that's good that's a good thing
i don't know if the right or the left
feel perfect about the way
that people are attacked they're
attacking pornhub because they've got
misogynistic content according to nick
kristoff at the new york times and
racist content
and because they've got underage girls
yeah definitely go after them for that
and because they've got fraud
videos and they've got okay fine that's
sort of death by a thousand cuts
and you're not going to eradicate
pornhub entirely but you are going to
cut it down to size just the other day
they deleted something like half of the
videos on their platform how many
millions of videos do they have on their
platform they deleted half of them
that's good that's good that's a win
that's a good standard to have and you
know when people say you can't legislate
morality well that's obviously
ridiculous
all laws by definition legislate
morality but i think what people are
really saying is
you can't have a you know establish this
perfect moral society without any sin
yeah duh of course not of course people
are going to violate these sorts of
things but you can at least have the
standard
and that goes a long way what we've done
what what really what political
correctness has done for the past 50
years 100 years
is to invert the standards that we have
in this country you saw this on espn
forget about porn for a second and go to
something even less savory espn
espn commentator and former football
player i guess
dominique foxworth a man i've never
heard of before
because i said not only do i not watch
espn now because it's gone woke but i
never really watched it all that much to
begin with
so dominique foxworth said on a podcast
that he roots against another player on
the buffalo bills josh allen
and it's not because he doesn't like
allen personally or you know he thinks
alan's bad player or whatever
it's because alan's fans are apparently
somewhat conservative and specifically
they have american flags in their social
media bios and because of that
this guy roots against josh allen
my biases are not based on josh allen
it's based on the people
that are defending josh allen i would be
100 lying
if i said that when josh does something
dumb a little part of me doesn't get
happy and it's not because i want josh
to succeed
it's because the people who are telling
me that josh
is the second coming and josh is better
than everybody
are people with american flags and dogs
and skull and crossbones in their abbeys
and then if you go just take a dip into
their
tweet history is some really concerning
retweets and likes some really
concerning retweets and likes
like i'm just gonna throw this out there
as a guess
do they like retweet trump or something
oh my gosh they do they retweet
us at the daily wire do they read do
they retweet conservatives what do they
have in the
in the bio they've got skull and
crossbones that's the jolly roger you
know kind of old pirate symbol it's kind
of like you know you see it on some
ties and things like that uh dogs oh no
dogs man's best friend nice wholesome
pet
and then worst of all the american flag
that's bad that's a warning sign
used to be according to the old
standards
that the american flag was unassailable
that was the one thing that we all could
agree on
because we all have to agree on it it's
it's the symbol
of the whole country
right it's not just a symbol it didn't
used to just be a symbol of the
republican party
or of uh magga or of uh
or i guess we all liked maga right we
all wanted to make america great again
uh it wasn't just a symbol of
conservative it was the symbol of all of
us and so we all saw ourselves there
and uh increasingly that is not so
i i suspect if you went to the left and
you
showed them either the rainbow flag the
sort of
gay rights el now it's more than that
though it's lgbt the whole
alphabet line if you show them that flag
or the american flag and said which one
do you feel represents you
i bet you even straight left wingers
a great many of them would choose the
rainbow flag
because the rainbow flag has become a
kind of it's it isn't even just a symbol
of lgbt anymore
it's a symbol of leftism in america
and it's an evidence not just the
rainbow flag but other
sorts of symbols like this it's an
evidence
that leftism is refuting something about
america and you don't need to look to
flags for that
you can see it in the 1619 project you
can see that in the
you can see that in the protests in the
nfl
protesting the symbol of the country
itself
that now now just conservatives are left
alone with this symbol of america
democrats tried to bring out a few flags
during their convention this year it
wasn't very convincing
they've moved on they're they're trying
to refute the country
they've got a new standard they've got a
new standard on sex obviously
but a new standard on politics generally
a new standard on science right we have
to defer to the
scientists not just on certain
medications
certain medical procedures but on
christmas on when we're allowed to
celebrate christmas that day used to be
set by the church authorities by bishops
by
you know by the early church fathers
now it's being set by british health
experts
what on earth do they have to do with
that now we're being told how we can
travel what family we can see
what we have to wear how we how we dress
is now being dictated to us
by this new scientific standard which is
obviously an
extreme bastardization of that term but
that is that is the new standard so what
what's the deal
are we going to celebrate our freedom
that ultimate freedom bought for us
by the incarnation then on the cross
that that freedom that has guided our
understanding of freedom
shaped it in our civilization for 2000
years
are we going to have some new idea for i
don't know what that
idea of freedom is from george clooney
and dr fauci
looks like an eternal lockdown which one
do we want this would be a good time of
year to contemplate that and make a
decision i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knoll show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production assistant
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there